BoBonsoir à vous.
- - Bonsoir.
- - Je disais en début d'émissi,
c'c'est un plaidoyer poignante.n
a a eu droit à Monsieur Zelensky
ququi depuis le début de cette
guguerre gagne haut la main la
guguerre des communications, et
d'd'être capable de toucher les
gegens sur le sort de son peuple
etet on l'a vu. Je vous fais
enentendre un exemple quand il t
alallé en disant : imaginez si s
bobombes tombaient à Vancouver u
sisi les bombes tombaient sur la
totour du CN. Imaginez si vous
dedeviez expliquer à vos enfants
popourquoi il y a des quartiers
dédétruits voici un extrait..
AvAvec elle cette demande qui le
fafait dans toute la capitale ùu
ilil se la rend virtuellement
dedemain il sera à Washington.
FeFermer l'espace aérien
ukukrainien. La réponse est
totoujours la même. Non. La Ruse
coconsidérerait cela comme une
atattaque direrecte de l'OTAN.
HéHélène, , est-ce que sur le f,
çaça ne bouge pas. Mais il
cocontinue à semer cet espoir en
didisant : j j'ai besoin de vout
bebesoin de gagner.
- - Oui. Vous l'avez dit. C'état
trtrès poignant et ce que j'ai
trtrouvé particulièrement
efefficace, percutant, et cette
fafaçon qu'il a eue au président
dede prendre personnellement
JuJustin Trudeau en disant :
JuJustin, imaginez c'était vos
enenfants qui se réveillaient la
nunuit au bruit domicile, imagiz
d'd'avoir à recevoir tous les
jojours le bilan des décès,
d'd'avoir il y a eu un total de7
enenfants décédés. Il y a cette
imimpuissance. Une communication
didirecte entre les deux hommes.
OnOn ramenait cela à un niveau
trtrès personnel en évoquant les
enenfants. On sait que Monsieur
TrTrudeau en a. Cela rendait les
memessages d'autant plus
pepercutants. Mais vous avavez
raraison. On est quand même dans
leles symboles ici parce qu'il y
a a rien sur le fond qui a chan.
CeCela même message véhiculé la
sesemaine passée sera la même ax
EÉtats-Unis. Vous savez, ces
didiscours à la chambre des
cocommunes de leaders étrangers
seserrent souvent à un objectif
popolitique c'était par exemplee
cacas en 2016 quand Barack Obama
ététait venu nous parler à la fn
dede son mandat. C'était pour
scsceller cette espèce d'amitié
enentre Monsieur Trudeau lui-mê.
OuOu alors même de mêler ses,
prprésident afghan et sa visite
vivisée à rehausser la popularié
dede mission canadienne dans ce
papays, qui commence à battre un
pepeu de l'aile. Il y a quelque
chchose quand même très politiqe
llà-dedans et cela vient apaiser
unune quelconque crête qui peut
exexister au Canada sur l'envoi
d'd'armes là-bas. Et c'est très
sysymbolique. Ça veut pas dire..
- - ça a permis de mesurer
vivisuellement que le consensus,
l'l'unanimité même d'appui à ce
papays en guerre. Stéphanie, la
chcheffe est conservatrice est
alallé un peu plus loin en disat
: : on devrait pouvoir protéger
dedes couloirs humanitaires en
UkUkraine, mais bon. Sur le fon,
ilil y a rien qui a changé.
- - Non, malheureusement. C'est
trtrès déchirant parce que oui,
enenvoie les gens qui
apapplaudissent, c'était poignat
d'd'avoir cette invasion que
MoMonsieur Zelensky a eue. Toute
momonde aurait envie d'applaudir
etet tout le monde se sentait
coconcerné. En voilà garçon nos
écécrans depuis 20 jours. Quand
elelle s'invite au Parlement et
ququand on fait le parallèle
didirectement avec le Canada,
évévidemment qu'on aurait envie
d'd'intervenir. Mais le problèm,
c'c'est que si on se rend aux
dedemandes de Monsieur Zelensky,
cecela va vouloir dire une
esescalade et dans le contexte
acactuel, personne n'avait avoir
unune troisième guerre mondialùu
onon a un despote qui pourrait
pepeser sur le bouton de l'arme
nunucléaire. C'est à tout prix e
ququ'on vu évitait. Est-ce que
cecela veut dire qu'il y a rien
ququ'on peut faire? Non. Je ne
pepense pas. Les sanctions
écéconomiques, il faut leur donr
lele temps de faire leur effet.e
n'n'est pas automatique et en
ququelques jours que la douleur
écéconomique se fait ressentir.l
y y a quand même espoir que cela
fafasse débloquer des choses. La
didiplomatie, je sais bien que e
n'n'est pas aujourd'hui qu'on a
l'l'impression que les choses
dédébloquent mais il faut essayr
jujusqu'au bout et peut-être aui
quque la Chine va pouvoir jouern
rrôle dans tout cela. Elle qui
s's'est présentée comme l'alliée
lala Russie et peut-être qu'elle
vava changer le discours parce
ququ'elle a aussi besoin, même i
c'c'est la deuxième grande
pupuissance économique du monde,
elelle a quand même besoin de
l'l'Occident et des États-Unis t
dede l'Europe pour faire son
cocommerce. Si jamais tout celae
momorcelait, ce serait pas très
bobon non plus pour la Chine.
ElElle est un peu un pays, un
gégéant parce que la demande
inintérieure de Marpa très forte
etet finalement, c'est cela. On
pepeut quand même continuer sur
seses fronts. Et sur le front
d'd'envoyer des armes sur le
teterrain pour que Monsieur
ZeZelensky puisse se défendre ms
popossible.
- - C'est comme si on lui disai:
tetenez bon. Durez est latent et
d'd'votre côté. La pression est
pepeut-être intenable pour
popoutine. Qui sait. Tenez bon.n
nene peut pas en faire plus.
- - Non et c'est vrai que la
guguerre est longue plus c'est
cocompliquée pour poutine. Elle
cocoûte très cher. Il faut qu'is
dédétiennent. Est-ce que ces
didiscours changent quelque cho?
PePeut-être pas à court terme.ÀA
lolong terme certainement. Le
pipinot public est mobilisé. La
cocommunication est une arme de
guguerre aussi. C'est l'un des
enendroits où Zelensky performe
bebeaucoup mieux que la Russie.l
enen fait et ancien comédien. Il
fafait très bien. Ça a permis ax
papays occidentaux n n'a pas reé
d'd'abord et ensuite pendant qul
mamanque d'inclusion aérienne il
sasait très bien qu'il ne peut s
obobtenir cela et c'était les ps
àà dire qu'on va faire plus et
enenvoyer plus d'armes et vous
aiaidez d'une autre manière. C't
lala stratégie des petits pas pr
quque les pays sont capables d'n
fafaire plus. Cela fonctionne
paparce qu'elle s'adressait pas
seseulement à Justin Trudeau
auaujourd'hui. Il est adressé à
totoute la Chambre des communest
cece qui est arrivé, le parti
coconservateur a fait un pas de
plplus en disant : on devrait
trtravailler la zone aérienne ds
cocouloirs humanitaires. On
dedevrait avoir une zone
d'd'exclusion pour les couloirs
huhumanitaires pour sa part la
plplus pour l'opposition. Il va
memettre de la pression sur Jusn
TrTrudeau. C'est comme cela que
trtranquillement, on va chercher
dudu côté des Zelensky plus
d'd'appui et de moyens et c'est
popour cela qu'elle parlait et
ququ'elle le peut à toutes les
cacapitales étrangères. Il a une
ststratégie pas
- - Hélène, la chef conservatrie
c'c'était oui pour mettre de la
prpression sur le gouvernement
TrTrudeau mais c'est quand mêmen
papas de plus. Que ce soit
huhumanitaire ou pas, c'est une
avavancée de plus d'aviation de
l'l'OTAN.
- - Oui et non. J'étais très
ététonné par cette sortie de
MaMadame et j'ai demandé des
prprécisions sur cette idée. Ce
cacannabisis a qu'on devrait à t
l'l'mois qui est une zone
d'd'exclusion aérienne au-dessus
dedes corridors humanitaires.
QuQuand j'ai demandé : comment
feferiez-vous cela? Et les
didiscours n'avait pas que l'OTN
asassure cette protection ou cee
exexclusion aérienne. Ce qu'on
prpropose, c'est l'envoi d'avios
chchasseurs comme cette
trtransaction qui n'a pas
fofonctionné. On propose par
exexemple des systèmes de missis
anantiaériens de style stinger,n
pepeut porter cela à l'épaule et
ababattre des avions. Déjà les
EÉtats-Unis en fournissent. Bre,
ququand on attend un peu, non ls
coconservateurs ne proposent paà
l'l'OTAN d'Alexandrie des
cocorridors. Ils ont l'air d'ête
dudu côté de l'Ukraine mais dans
lele fond il est quand même pas
mamal le consensus internationa.
- - Très bien.
IlIl a donné le nom...
ququand je disais poignant, 97
enenfants sont morts. C'est
prprécis. C'est dur. Envoie les
imimages tout de suite. OK.
OnOn change de sujet. Rentrée
paparlementaire à Québec : on va
écécouter Madame Anglade et
MoMonsieur Legault.
C'C'est sur la question des tars
d'd'Hydro-Québec Monsieur Legaut
a a parlé avant mais je voulais
afaffecter après qui explique
ququ'elle attrapa Hydro-Québec
auaugmentée de cinq ou 6 % des
tatarifs.
DODOMINIQUE ANGLADE, cheffe de
l'l'opposition officielle, Québc
- - Le premier ministre est
totoujours en train de regarder
enen arrière, incapable
d'd'anticiper. Lorsque...
LoLorsqu'on a dit qu'il y aurait
dedes risques importants
enen matière d'inflation,
ququ'est-ce que le premier
miministre nous a dit?
IlIl a répondu, Monsieur
lele président, "Je vais inviter
lala cheffe du Parti libéral
d'd'arrêter d'exagérer."
- - Je comprends que la cheffe
dede l'opposition officielle
nene veut pas regarder en arriè,
nene veut pas regarder l'ancien
chchef du Parti libéral, qui vet
mamaintenant construire
dedes oléoducs qui vont passer
auau Québec, Monsieur le
prprésident. C'est ça, l'ancien
PaParti libéral. Je comprends
ququ'elle souhaiterait que ça
exexiste pas, ce passé-là, mais
MoMonsieur le président, le Pari
lilibéral a augmenté les tarifs
dede plus que l'inflation.
L'L'année prochaine, si
l'l'inflation est à un niveau
exexceptionnel, on va remettre e
l'l'argent dans le portefeuille.
- - Il y aura pas d'augmentation
dede 4, 5 % ou plus des tarifs
d'd'électricité le 1er avril 20.
OnOn va prendre les moyens
popour compenser les Québécois,
mamais il y aura pas
d'd'augmentation de 4, 5 %.
CeCe qu'on parle, pour l'instan,
c'c'est une aide spéciale
nonon récurrente pour l'année 22
popour couvrir l'inflation
acactuelle. Maintenant, pour les
tatarifs d'électricité en 2023,
llà aussi, il y aura une aide
ququi est ponctuelle. Maintenan,
esest-ce que la CAQ proposera
dedes baisses d'impôts
pepermanentes? Bien là, je vous
ininvite à attendre la campagne
élélectorale.
- - D'une certaine façon.
StStéphanie je commence avec vo.
OnOn notera que Monsieur Legault
vovoulait faire des détours pour
mmère et de Monsieur Sherret.
CeCela va revenir aussi. Sur
HyHydro-Québec, comme on les
didisait, il est pris avec sa li
etet va devoir moduler ou trouvr
unune façon pour ne pas, c'est
l'l'inflation continue l'an
prprochain, ont pas laissé Hydr-
QuQuébec de paix avec des 5 %.
- - C'est cela. C'était écrit ds
lele ciel en 2019. Il a passé sa
loloi qu'on risque de se retrour
dadans une situation comme cell-
llà. Les coudes Hydro-Québec
nonon pas de mesurer avec
ininflation. C'est ce qui fait e
l'l'on se retrouve avec des
auaugmentations énormes alors qe
lala cote PLUS chère à Hydro de
prproduire. Il y avait un
mémécanisme de régie d'énergie t
çaça fonctionnait pour essayer e
didire : quel est l'augmentation
raraisonnable? On devrait revenr
àà cela. C'est quand même étrane
quque ce soit le premier ministe
ququi décéda la pièce combien ls
QuQuébécois...
- - est-ce que ces deux aux
trtrois....
- - ce n'est pas sérieux. Est-ce
quque je pourrais dire, il y a
pepeut-être lieu que les gens, s
méménages étaient plus chers
élélectricité préservent par une
trtransition énergétique, on va
avavoir besoin de beaucoup plus
d'd'énergie et d'électricité, et
sisi on veut encourager les genà
momoins gaspiller, en envoyant n
sisignal de prix très bon moyen.
C'C'est pas en gelant les tarifs
quque l'on encourage les gens à
fafaire la meilleure utilisation
dede leur énergie. Peut-être que
c'c'est une bonne chose informee
fafaudrait pas que cela se fasse
enen cachette sous le couvert de
l'l'inflation. Un débat de socié
ququ'on devait avoir ouvertement
papas
- - Et les diront jamais mais
pepeut-être qu'il regrette un pu
d'd'avoir mit la hache dans la
rérégie de l'énergie parce qu'iy
avavait un mécanisme, c'était
cocompliqué. Hydro allait plaid.
IlIl y avait comme un mécanisme
ququi était là. Comment on fait
mamaintenant?
- - C'était une erreur à l'époqe
dede modifier la manière dont
fifixent les tarifs. C'est encoe
plplus flagrant que c'est une
ererreur aujourd'hui. La régie a
étété créée pour être démesurémt
l'l'aspect politique et jouer ac
leles tarifs, il y avait une
raraison. On se rend compte
auaujourd'hui. Même quand on
vovoulait fixer l'inflation autr
dede 2 % c'était quand même deux
fofois plus que les récents tars
HyHydro-Québec annuels qui
asassaillent entre 0,6 0,8. Il
n'n'avait pas besoin être fixé à
l'l'inflation. C'était déjà un
cacadeau. Imaginez à 2,6 et quae
etet 5 %. Si on envoie un chèque
popour compenser, la hausse de %
rereste. L'année d'après on va n
ajajouter une autre.
- - Augmenter la marche.
- - On a 4 % et on envoie un pet
chchèque. 400 $ aux Québécois ms
apaprès ça on ajoute un autre 2.
OnOn envoie plus de chèques apr.
L'L'inflation est revenue à la
nonormale. Honnêtement, c'est un
mémécanisme qui tout croche et n
dedevrait revenir à quelque choe
dede scientifique avec des expes
cocomme c'était le cas avant. Le
gogouvernement devrait dire qu'n
a a fait une erreur et qu'on
n'n'avait pas prévu cela. On
rerevient au mécanisme d'avant t
cecela fait mal à l'approche d'e
cacampagne, mais ce serait la
bobonne solution.
- - Il a déjà fait. Quand il
vovoit...
- - il est capable de s'excuser.
IlIl est capable de reconnaître
ququ'il n'avait pas prévu cela.n
momoment donné, il faut aussi
prprendre acte.
- - Sinon tu fais quoi?
UnUne personne à l la formule
mamagique? Hélène, je veux que
vovous me parliez de Jean
ChCharest... non Monsieur Legau.
IlIl veut passer des oléoducs et
c'c'est votre ancien chef, c'est
cece que Monsieur Legault disaià
AnAnglade. Il voulait en parler.
IlIl attendait une question sur
MoMonsieur Charest.
- - Il va peut-être leur requêt.
LaLa prochaine échéance est une
écéchéance électorale provincia.
DoDonc, cela lui permet évidemmt
dede s'attaquer aux libéraux ete
fafaire toutes les blagues que
l'l'on a entendues aujourd'hui t
ququi vont se répéter assurémen.
MaMais admettons que Monsieur
ChCharest devait devenir le chef
dudu parti conservateur et on
veverra bien. D'abord, il va ête
chchoisi en plein milieu de la
cacampagne provinciale en passa.
OnOn l'a vu dans le passé : la
clclaque souhaitée l'élection dn
gogouvernement conservateur à
OtOttawa. Ce qu'il a pris comme
poposition dans la dernière
cacampagne et il y a des affinis
ididéologiques entre la cAQ et e
paparti conservateur fédéral. Si
MoMonsieur Charest devait devenr
chchef et que tout d'un coup
MoMonsieur Legault pourrait
vovouloir souhaiter son élection
ilil serait pris avec des
dédéclarations parce qu'il serat
emembarrassante.
- - Il y a des scénarios
inintéressants. Mais on n'est ps
llà. Cela commence, la course
chchez les conservateur. Un pett
momot là-dessus, Alec? Le désire
MoMonsieur Legault dans la moyee
pepetite à Monsieur Charest aprs
- - C'est une bonne guerre. Jean
ChCharest a une image dans
l'l'opinion publique. Les gens t
unune opinion de lui et elle est
nénégative passablement. Cela va
lului prendre du temps pour
auaugmenter son image.
MoMonsieur le Guatapé Parti
lilibéral. Ce n'est pas étonnan.
- - On verra cela régie de
l'l'énergie va renaître de ses
cecendres. Merci beaucoup à vou